[Music]  ben shapiro is against joe biden's  student loan debt forgiveness what a big  surprise his idea is here's the way to  avoid student loan debt  don't take out debt that you can't pay  back or that it's not worth  taking out based on the job that you're  going to get well that's very easy to  say  except it's completely unrealistic first  and foremost the relative cost of  education to wages has exploded and it  is not as simple as saying well i'll  just opt out because increasingly jobs  require one of those degrees so does  that mean that there's a problem of  course the system is completely broken  but the idea of just don't take it out  if you don't think you're going to be  able to pay it back people are pushed  into taking on these debts because  increasingly jobs say you've got to have  a college degree